تقدر قيمه الاسلحه والذخيره المسروقه من
مستودعات الجيش الاسرائيلي بالملايين هذه
الاسلحه تباع بالسوق السوداء باضعاف
اسعارها الحقيقيه والكلام لصحيفه يدعوت
احرنوت من الذي يسرق من الجيش الاسرائيلي
ولماذا يسرق هل حاميها حراميها مثلا
اسمعوا هذه القصه هذه صوره نتنياهو عندما
زار الجنود في غزه وحوله جنود من نخبه
الشاباك وهذا الجندي الصنديد من نخبه قوات
الشاباك كما هو ظاهر وها هو مدجج كره
الكمات نزاله لا ممعنا هربا ولا
مستسلم
مجعبة
اسمه الحقيقي روي فراخ من سكان تلبين عمره
35 عاما لم يخدم ابدا في الجيش
الاسرائيلي مره انتحل صفه شرطي ومره اخرى
صفه جندي في وحده مكافحه الارهاب امام
وتاره يظهر بهيئه عميل في الشاباك نشرت
القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه صورته مع
رئيس الوزراء وتقول انه متهم بانتحال
شخصيه عسكري وسرقه اسلحه استط ععت السلطات
الاسرائيليه القبضه على هذا المحتال يوري
فراغ يا فراخ وتقول انه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الى تاريخ اعتقاله في الساب عش من
ديسمبر كانون الاول سرق ي فراخ هذين
الشهرين خلال هذين الشهرين اسلحه وذخائر
هاه ذخائر متنوعه قنابل يدويه خراطيش رصاص
بدلات عسكريه واجهزه اتصال لا سلكيه لك
حتى طائره درون سرقها ثروا على على كل هذه
المسروقات في سيارته وشقته وشقه والدته
جاء في لائحه الاتهام انه خلال حاله
الطوارئ التي تعيشها دوله اسرائيل قدم
المتهم نفسه كمقاتل ويشغل مناصب في
الاجهزه الامنيه والوحدات الخاصه من اجل
سرقه كميه كبيره من الاسلحه والذخائر
والمعدات محامي الجندي الحرامي قال انه
عامل مسعفا وانقذ ارواحا وكان يخاطر
بحياته وي الارهابيين بموافقه الجيش
الاسرائيلي وباستخدام المعدات التي حصل
عليها يعني سرقها من الجيش فمن العبث ان
تلاحق اسرائيل التي فشلت في حمايه
مواطنيها مواطنا تطوع لحمايتها المقصر هو
الدوله وليس روي يا فراخ انتم علقتم على
هذه الفضيحه التي طالت الجيش الاسرائيلي
كيف وصل هذا الشخص بهذه
السهوله الى اسلحه الجيش وحيد مجدي يقول
لك اذا كان كان سرقوا الارض مش يسرقوا
حاجه زي دي دائما بحاولوا تربح حتى من جلد
الاموات احلام عثمان يقول لك الله ليقيم
على قلوبهم شده ما خلو شيء من من
الفلسطينيين وما سرقوه اجا الدور عليهم
ويسرقوا بعض ابو ناصر قال لك اجمل شيء
دفاع المحامي عن السارق وكيف قلب الحقائق
هذه سياسه اسرائيل الدوله لخصها هذا
المحامي يارا قالت يعني كيف انتحل صفه
جندي ليش هو جيش الدفاع وكاله من غير بواب
معقول يعني اللي اللي بنسمعه الجندي داخل
المعسكر ما بيقدر يتحرك من قطاع لاخر بدون
اذن مسبق من الضابط المسؤول عنه كيف هذا
عم يصول
ويجول على كل حال تنتظر روي خمس تهم منها
سرقه والاحتيال وانتحال شخصيه جندي وقد
تصل عقوباتها لاكثر من
36 عاما في السجن